David Boder: [In English] This is spool number 28. An interview with Lieutenant André Richard from Paris, by means of an interpreter, Miss Bertha Goldwasser...Miss Bertha Goldwasser...now...a...eh...
David Boder: [In German] Now, wollen Sie ihn bitten, dass er seinen Namen sagt und wie alt er ist und was er jetzt tut?
Bertha Goldwasser: [In French] Si vous voulez Monsieur Richard, dire votre nom, votre adresse, votre profession et quel âge vous avez ?
André Richard: André Richard, 2 Cité Condorcet, Paris IXème. Je suis artiste au Théâtre National de l’Opéra à Paris.
David Boder: [In German] Wollen Sie ihn fragen, was er getan hat und wo er war, wenn die Deutschen nach Paris gekommen?
Bertha Goldwasser: [In French] Si vous voulez bien gentiment nous dire qu’est ce que vous avez fait pendant l’Occupation ici à Paris ?
André Richard: Ce que j’ai fait pendant l’Occupation, je suis entré dans la Résistance, sous les ordres du commandant Bordé et du colonel Goisé. Le commandant Bordé a formé le groupe la Marseillaise. Le groupe la Marseillaise comprenait trois sections, c’est-à-dire trois groupes. Et chaque groupe de la Marseillaise était commandé par un lieutenant, et nous avions pour chef le commandant Bordé. Dans ces groupes la Marseillaise sont venus se joindre à nous des Francs Tireurs n’est-ce pas, des partisans volontaires qui voulaient être libres et n’appartenir et n’avoir aucun chef. Ils acceptaient volontiers les missions qu’on pouvait leur confier et, à leurs risques et périls, nous rapportaient et accomplissaient ces...les dites missions qui étaient d’ailleurs parfois très dangereuses...car je n’ai pas connu de mission qui ne soit pas dangereuse pendant l’Occupation. C’est d’ailleurs à mon avis ce qui fait la valeur, la grande valeur des vrais résistants qui eux sont restés pendant toute l’Occupation au contact de l’ennemi. Voilà ce que j’appelle les vrais résistants. Maintenant, il y a une chose que je me permets de signaler en passant, c’est qu’un jour, en allant voir un de mes camarades qui devait nous donner l’heure du passage de certains trains de permissionnaires allemands, j’ai eu l’idée...j’ai eu l’idée de mettre, avant le départ de ces dits trains, j’ai eu l’idée de mettre, en collaboration avec des gens de mon groupe, hommes et femmes, de mettre des prospectus, des tracts pour démoraliser les Allemands. J’ai parlé au commandant Bordé ainsi qu’au colonel Goisé de...mon idée, ma petite invention si je puis dire, et tous deux l’ont acceptée. C’est alors que j’ai commencé seul, avec une musette, je suis passé dans la gare n’est-ce pas, dans la dite musette il y avait un litre de vin, un morceau de pain et les tracts étaient en dessous. Je suis passé dans la gare et dans les trains, j’ai inondé les trains partout, dans les waters, partout où les Allemands pouvaient aller. Et naturellement l’effet ne s’est pas fait attendre car le lendemain, la Gestapo commençait déjà ses recherches dans les gares. Alors nous avons dû attendre une quinzaine de jours et après nous avons recommencé dans les différentes gares, dans les différentes gares nous avons recommencé à redistribuer des tracts partout. C’était alors que j’ai donné des tracts à différents camarades n’est-ce pas, qui d’ailleurs se sont fort bien accomplis de la mission dont je les avais chargés.
David Boder: [In German] Now, äh, was waren die Anfänge von der Résistance? Wer hat die Résistance formiert? Waren da gewisse Gruppen, die schon bevor die Deutschen kamen, sich zusammengelegt haben, um zu resistieren?
Bertha Goldwasser: [In French] Monsieur le professeur vous demande, Monsieur Richard, est-ce que les groupes de résistance étaient préparés avant l’Occupation ici à Paris, où la résistance était formée et comment, et quel caractère elle a pris en général ?
André Richard: Et bien les groupes à mon avis de résistance, n’étaient pas formés avant l’Occupation car...nous...pour moi, à mon avis personnel c’est que nous avons été trahis sur toute la ligne, du plus haut jusqu’au plus petit. Maintenant, les groupes se sont formés parce que nous nous sommes retrouvés plusieurs camarades, tous, la mort dans l’âme et j’ai vu, ainsi que moi-même, beaucoup de camarades qui ont vu rentrer les Allemands dans Paris, les larmes aux yeux. C’est-à-dire nous, nous avions les larmes aux yeux de voir rentrer les Allemands dans Paris. Et bien, nous nous sommes reportés...à la pensée de la guerre de soixante dix, où les Allemands ont foulé, n’est-ce pas le sol de Paris, et naturellement nous nous sommes reportés à cette date-là en pensant que nos grands-pères avaient eu la même souffrance que nous et c’est alors que plusieurs eurent l’idée, n’est-ce pas, de dire mais au fait, si on organisait des groupes pour se voir et démolir ce que les Allemands pourraient faire, nous rendre utiles à quelque chose. Et c’est alors que sont commencés...ont commencé à se former les groupes de résistance mais rien n’était formé avant, enfin à ma connaissance, car j’ai travaillé dans le groupe Turenne, qui était commandé par le colonel Goisé, un homme de toute valeur, de grande valeur je puis dire, car le colonel Goisé a risqué, et à ma connaissance et à ma vue puisque j’ai été présent plusieurs fois, ça a été un de mes plus grands chefs, d’ailleurs je suis étonné que le colonel Goisé ne soit pas encore décoré de la Légion d’Honneur. Tous mes camarades officiers et moi-même, nous en sommes même indignés car le colonel Goisé a fait plusieurs fois abstraction de sa vie, et bien, il a réussi à s’en sortir, j’en suis très heureux, mes camarades aussi...mais néanmoins, bien souvent, quand il y avait des situations qui étaient très périlleuses, le colonel Goisé partait avant nous, et nous n’avions qu’à arriver, le travail était déjà à moitié fait. Je rends ici un hommage public au colonel Goisé car on a oublié de le récompenser, ainsi que plusieurs autres. Mais, à en revenir pour les groupes de la Résistance, et bien je maintiens mon avis, à mon avis rien n’était organisé. Et l’élan, l’élan si je puis dire, de tous les groupes de la Résistance a été donné le jour où nous avons entendu notre chef suprême, le général Charles de Gaulle. Et c’est là qu’est venue...qu’est venue l’idée de généraliser la Résistance par des groupes, par des Francs Tireurs partisans, par des Corps Francs Volontaires, des...des gens n’est-ce pas, qui étaient...que l’on appelait dans la clandestinité...enfin que l’on appelait, que les Allemands appelaient dans la clandestinité n’est-ce pas, enfin dans...sous l’Occupation, que des gens appelaient terroristes, ces gens-là n’est-ce pas étaient appelés terroristes, en réalité ce n’était pas des terroristes, pour nous c’était simplement des héros. Et bien souvent, bien souvent, ces gens-là...d’ailleurs oui, à ma connaissance, ceux avec qui j’ai travaillé, il n’en est pas revenu beaucoup. Je peux même dire que quand le tunnel de Maintenon...a sauté à Rouen avec les trains...a sauté, et ainsi qu’à Rouen avec les trains de munitions, et bien aucun n’est revenu, aucun, aucun...et j’ai dû rentrer seul porter à mes chefs, n’est-ce pas, porter au colonel Goisé ainsi qu’à Roger Bordé, n’est-ce pas, le commandant Bordé, j’ai dû rentrer tout seul et lui dire, n’est-ce pas ce que...ce que j’avais appris et comment ça s’était passé, enfin les renseignements qu’on m’avait apportés, et bien souvent je suis rentré seul alors que nous étions partis à une vingtaine, et je suis rentré seul de ces missions, qui étaient vraiment périlleuses.
David Boder: [In German] Ich stell jetzt eine andere Frage: Man hat in Amerika soviel gesprochen darüber, dass man am Anfang den Krieg verloren hat, weil die Arbeiter gegen den Krieg waren und den Krieg sabotiert haben.
Bertha Goldwasser: [In French] Monsieur le professeur me dit de vous demander...il me dit de vous dire l’opinion de l’Amérique, car en Amérique, on ne [inaudible] cette opinion...que la guerre ici en France était terrible [inaudible] parce que les ouvriers n’ont pas voulu, euh...n’ont pas voulu se mobiliser et aller à la guerre et puis, ils ont saboté dans l’usine [inaudible], est-ce que c’est vrai ?
André Richard: Et bien je lui dirais que...les ouvriers, n’est-ce pas...à ma connaissance, les ouvriers ont fait leur devoir...les ouvriers font toujours leur devoir.
David Boder: [In German] [He said something in the background - unintelligible]
Bertha Goldwasser: [In German] Herr Richard sagt, dass der Arbeiter in Frankreich hat nicht sabotiert. Er hat sich gestellt im Beruf, er hat sich gestellt für auf den Platz, man hat ihn geführt. Aber Frankreich und die ganze Kriegs...[unverständlich] um den Regierung, und an weil die Krieg war schon gekauft im Jahre 38. Also der Arbeiter in Frankreich war nur reserviert, als Soldat hat er nicht...[unverständlich]. Aber weil er hat gesehen, dass er mit...[unverständlich] lebendig in die Hände als Gefangener von den Feind als Gefangener. Dann hat er sich zurückgezogen. Meine Meinung ist, dass jeder von uns hätte das auch gemacht.
David Boder: Ja, nun will er weiter sagen, wie kam denn die, äh, wie wenn sich die Résistance entwickelt hat. Welche Gruppen haben hauptsächlich die Résistance gewollt?
Bertha Goldwasser: [In French] Le professeur vous demande, quand la Résistance s’est groupée, que vous citiez ici les noms des groupes lesquels sont...ont commencé à aider la Résistance.
André Richard: Les groupes, n’est-ce pas, les groupes, à eux seuls formaient la Résistance, la Résistance n’étaient formée que de groupes, que l’on appelait n’est-ce pas, soit par exemple réseau Turenne n’est-ce pas, le groupe Turenne, réseau la Marseillaise, le groupe la Marseillaise, vous aviez Libération Nord, vous aviez...les maquis de Haute-Savoie, vous aviez les maquis de Bretagne, vous aviez le maquis de Normandie n’est-ce pas, le maquis de Normandie a été fondé par un lieutenant russe qui avait réussi à s’évader, avec lequel je suis rentré en contact étant moi-même normand n’est-ce pas, et bien ce lieutenant russe, n’est-ce pas, est d’ailleurs reparti en Russie, j’ai l’ai vu souvent à Paris, nous sommes devenus des amis, c’est le lieutenant...euh...Dadachov. Et bien le lieutenant Dadachov n’est-ce pas, c’est lui-même qui avait eu l’idée, il a eu l’idée elle-même qui a fondé le...le premier maquis en Normandie. Je suis entré en contact avec lui parce que Dadachov, n’est-ce pas, était...s’était réfugié en Normandie, se cachait en Normandie et avait fondé le maquis de Normandie. Je suis rentré en contact avec lui parce que je suis Normand et que...je me suis fait connaître à lui et qu’il a eu confiance en moi, et alors de là, nous nous sommes revus à Paris et...nous avons resté en contact avec le commandant Bordé et nous nous sommes mis souvent en contact pour...des...des choses n’est-ce pas, des...des missions à remplir, des missions mutuelles, c’est-à-dire le sabotage complet de l’ennemi, soit de faire sauter les trains, soit n’est-ce pas de...de voler, de...de voler le ravitaillement de l’ennemi, soit d’incendier...d’incendier les...les camions qui stationnaient sur les routes, soit de déboulonner les rails, enfin de faire mille choses, mille choses de sabotage, que même, n’est-ce pas...je me demande si je referais n’est-ce pas cette chose-là étant donné que l’ennemi n’est plus là, et qu’on me commanderait de faire ces choses-là, je me demande si vraiment...nous avons fait des choses à la Résistance qui sont invraisemblables, il fallait vraiment que nous soyons emportés par l’élan patriotique de sauver, par tous les moyens, notre belle France et d’obéir à l’...au...à comment dirais-je, à l’ordre solennel de notre chef suprême le général Charles de Gaulle, n’est-ce pas, et alors, entraînés par lui, par sa voix, par ses...comment dirais-je, par ses communiqués, n’est-ce pas que nous écoutions clandestinement car il fallait nous méfier quand nous entendions les...la radio anglaise, n’est-ce pas il fallait nous méfier, et bien...nous étions capables à ce moment-là, tellement nous étions galvanisés par Charles de Gaulle notre chef suprême, de faire n’importe quoi, n’importe quoi. Et nous avions des chefs, il faut bien le dire, que ce soit le colonel Goisé, que ce soit le commandant Bordé ou le capitaine Allard, et bien nous avions des gens vraiment qui nous galvanisaient et qui...nous disaient mais il y va, il y va, il y va de l’avenir de la France. Or, vous me parliez de l’ouvrier tout à l’heure, et bien l’ouvrier n’est-ce pas, l’ouvrier français pour moi a fait son devoir n’est-ce pas, parce que...il a tout fait pour la France, et je suis...je suis sûr que demain, il est encore prêt à faire tout pour la France.
David Boder: [In German] What was the, äh, was war die das Verhältnis meisten der Universitätsprofessoren zu der Résistance?
Bertha Goldwasser: [In French] Les professeurs...Comment se sont comportés les professeurs de l’Université, en général les intellectuels pour la Résistance ? Est-ce que les intellectuels ont fait aussi la Résistance ?
André Richard: Oui, certains...certains professeurs ont fait la Résistance...mais pas tous, pas tous parce que...il y avait évidemment les collaborateurs. N’est-ce pas, on ne peut pas, même parmi les intellectuels il y a eu...j’ai eu dans mon groupe, et j’ai vu dans les autres groupes, et bien des intellectuels, même dans les Francs Tireurs Partisans, j’ai connu de grands intellectuels, n’est-ce pas, même des professeurs qui ont fait leur devoir, et qui n’étaient pas des collaborateurs comme certains, maintenant évidemment chacun avait son opinion, ses idées mais...j’ai connu des gens, je le...je le répète, des gens, des professeurs et des intellectuels qui étaient dans la Résistance et qui ont fait tout leur devoir.
David Boder: [In German] And dieselbe Frage, äh, wie haben sich die Schauspieler, das Theater und die Literatur zu der, zu den Deutschen und der Résistance verhalten?
Bertha Goldwasser: [In French] Comment se sont comportés les artistes français et aussi...le...les littéraires, les écrivains, les danseurs, plusieurs euh...tous ceux qui sont dans cette corporation ?
André Richard: Et bien dans cette corporation, évidemment il y eu malheureusement beaucoup de collaborateurs, mais enfin, il y a eu des gens qui n’ont pas collaboré. Evidemment...je puis dire qu’il y a eu à peu près dans la proportion...dans la proportion de...60 à 80 %...de gens qui ont collaboré parmi les artistes, comme parmi les gens de la littérature, comme parmi les journalistes, d’ailleurs vous n’avez pas été sans voir, n’est-ce pas que l’on a mis à l’index certains artistes, certains écrivains et même certains, enfin, dans la littérature et même certains professeurs également, dans la danse c’est pareil, dans la danse il y eu un pourcentage n’est-ce pas, de 50 à 60 % de collaboration. Ca ne retire pas le talent de ces...de ces artistes, de ces danseurs, de ces écrivains mais néanmoins, il est tout de même regrettable, et...nous avons à déplorer cette chose-là, c’est une...n’est-ce pas, la littérature...le...les artistes, la danse, tout ça, et bien oh, ce qui était français aurait dû rester français et n’aurait pas dû s’imprégner des choses allemandes. Maintenant, j’espère que...un effort va être fait pour oublier tout ça et que tous...et toutes repartiront du bon pied.
David Boder: [In German] Ich möchte jetzt wissen, sind viele und, sind viele vom Militär aktiv mit den Deutschen mitgegangen?
Bertha Goldwasser: [In French] Monsieur le professeur vous demande, est-ce que beaucoup...des militaires, des soldats, des...des gradés même, étaient avec les Allemands ?...Est-ce que beaucoup de militaires...
David Boder: [In German] The interviewer interrupts interpreter here I can’t tell what language it is [unintelligible]
Bertha Goldwasser: [In French]...de militaires, des...des gradés, est-ce qu’ils collaboraient avec des Allemands directement ?
André Richard: Oh ben à ma connaissance n’est-ce pas...heu oui il y a eu beaucoup d’officiers qui malheureusement ont collaboré, d’ailleurs il n’y a qu’à reprendre les jugements faits jusqu’à présent par les tribunaux français, ça vous donnera une idée de ce que les officiers, de certains officiers français, ont collaboré malheureusement...je suis même étonné s’ils étaient vraiment des...des...ce que l’on appelle des vrais Français. Car un vrai Français, à mon avis, ne collabore pas avec un ennemi. Ca...pour moi c’est, c’est la forme même presque de la psychiatrie, c’est un fou...tout simplement.
Bertha Goldwasser: [In German] Herr Richard sagt, dass man soll durchschauen die kritischen Gesetzen und auch die im Krieg...[unverständlich] Verhandlungen. Dann wird man sehen, wie viele im Dienst verurteilte gewordene Militärleute von Frankreich, die welche haben mit den Deutschen kollaboriert. So, und in Kontakt gestanden.
David Boder: . . . Nun, was denkt er, wie wird sich jetzt in Frankreich das alles entwickeln, bis es normal wird?
Bertha Goldwasser: [In French] Comment pensez-vous, Monsieur Richard, voir maintenant arranger...ici dans la France, la vie, comment elle va revenir, et dans quel...quel avenir nous attend ?
André Richard: Moi vous savez, l’avenir nous attend, c’est que, à l’heure actuelle, la politique, n’est-ce pas est une chose que je ne comprends pas, et que je ne cherche pas à comprendre, car vous savez, les gens qui font de la politique, sont des gens qui sont déjà à moitié fous, et qui ne cherchent qu’une chose, leur profit avant de chercher le profit du pays. Si il y avait des hommes capables de pouvoir faire une politique pour relever vraiment et dignement la France, car la France est un pays qui ne peut pas sombrer, il est trop beau, et c’est un pays qui vraiment a montré, par tous les moyens, que ce soit dans n’importe quelle branche, il a montré ce pays qu’il pouvait pas sombrer parce que il est trop grand et trop puissant, il a un passé vraiment trop grand. Mais, il faudrait à la tête de la France des hommes dignes de pouvoir la conduire...à la hauteur qu’elle mérite. Et ces hommes, il faudrait que ce soit des gens comme Gambetta, comme Jaurès, n’est-ce pas, des gens qui feraient abstraction de tout, des saints mais à mon avis, il n’y en a plus...il n’y en a plus car les gens, à l’heure actuelle sont trop matériels. Vouloir, n’est-ce pas, vouloir, c’est...mener la France, à la hauteur, je le répète n’est-ce pas, à la hauteur qu’elle mérite, et bien c’est un imposteur qui n’appartient pas aux hommes actuels.
David Boder: [In German] Äh, will er uns sagen, welcher in seiner Aktivität der gefährlichste Moment gewesen ist?
Bertha Goldwasser: [In French] Est-ce que vous pouvez nous citer le cas dans le moment, que vous avez...dans le moment de votre mission qui était le plus dangereux ?
André Richard: Le cas dans les missions qui a été le plus dangereux, et bien, c’est quand je suis allé...quand je suis allé, n’est-ce pas, pour réveiller tous les pauvres types qui devaient aller faire sauter, n’est-ce pas les...les ouvrages allemands. Et bien j’avais dans une musette, et dans une petite valise, tout du moins dans un petit sac, j’avais des explosifs, et, je côtoyais, sur les boulevards, dans les rues, des tas d’Allemands. Le plus pénible pour moi, c’est le jour que je suis allé porter, à des camarades, des explosifs et que je me suis trouvé pris dans une rafle. Et bien, j’ai dû mon salut qu’à un brave gardien de la paix, que je connaissais, n’est-ce pas, qui s’appelle Thomas, le brigadier Thomas, de la...qui est à la...au poste de la mairie du IXème arrondissement à Paris, le brigadier Thomas justement était mon sous-chef de groupe. Et ce brave Thomas, justement c’est lui, avec moi, qui avons planté le drapeau français à la Kommandantur, que nous avons prise d’assaut place de l’Opéra. Et bien...que nous avons prise à la Libération. Et bien ce brave Thomas, justement c’est grâce à lui, que j’ai pu...c’est lui qui m’a fait passer, qui m’a fait sortir de la rafle, et j’ai pu ainsi échapper, aux mains et aux questions n’est-ce pas des...de la Feldgendarmerie allemande. Et c’est grâce à lui, car vraiment je puis le dire, c’est lui qui m’a sauvé la vie. Et bien...Thomas justement, qui a été un des résistants, enfin le plus, à mon avis parmi la police, le plus épatant, et bien...est aussi lui à l’heure actuelle resté dans l’ombre.
David Boder: [In German] Äh, waren äh welche komischen Momente, äh, in diesem äh, in äh, während der äh des Daseins der Deutschen hier? Sind da welche Anekdoten, die man von denen erzählt?
Bertha Goldwasser: [In French] Euh, Monsieur le professeur vous demande est-ce qu’il y a aussi, des moments comiques, qu’on peut raconter, du passé, quand il y avait des Allemands ici ?
André Richard: Et bien il y en a, oui il y en a, parce que vraiment...les Allemands étaient par moment très comiques. Et un jour justement, en sortant de chez moi boulevard Barbès, j’ai rencontré, n’est-ce pas, une...une colonie de petits enfants juifs qui étaient conduits, n’est-ce pas, des pauvres gosses qui avaient l’étoile jaune...qui avaient l’étoile jaune sur la poitrine...et ces pauvres petits enfants, et bien étaient conduits par deux femmes qui également portaient l’étoile. Un jour un de ces enfants est tombé, et s’est mis à pleurer. Je n’ai pas pu m’empêcher, que de me baisser et de le ramasser. Je lui ai essuyé la figure et je l’ai embrassé. Et je l’ai embrassé avec d’autant plus de ferveur et beaucoup plus de chaleur, que ce petit garçon portait l’étoile. Et que je me rendais compte qu’il était lui-même malgré son jeune âge, il avait quel âge mon dieu ? Sept, huit ans...même pas il avait...cinq, six ans. Et il avait l’étoile, et il...lui qu’avait-il fait pour mériter le martyre des Allemands ? Rien. Alors je l’ai donc embrassé, je l’ai remis debout, il a rejoint tous ses petits camarades. A ce moment-là passaient deux Allemands, qui m’ont regardé et qui avaient l’air de dire, n’est-ce pas de m’approuver de l’avoir relevé et de l’avoir embrassé. Mais quand ils ont vu que ce gosse, avait l’étoile sur la poitrine, ils m’ont jeté un regard de mépris, et se sont regardés tous les deux, et déçus d’avoir approuvé que j’avais relevé ce gosse sont partis comme deux péteux. Maintenant, il y a une autre histoire. Il y a une autre histoire et malheureusement, n’est-ce pas...ce sont des histoires mais qui sont vraies. C’est un officier allemand qui suit une très belle fille, en deuil. Et cette femme est en deuil, parce qu’elle a perdu un des siens, également tué par les Allemands. Mais cette femme est suivie par un officier allemand, qui monocle dans l’œil n’est-ce pas, la complimente et lui demande un renseignement, et à chaque fois, cette femme se dérobe pour ne pas répondre à l’officier allemand. Excédé, l’officier allemand vient carrément devant ladite femme, qui était je le répète très belle, et lui demande et lui dit : « madame, voulez-vous me dire le nom de cette rue? ». Alors courageusement la femme le regarde dans les yeux, écarte son crêpe de deuil, et montre son étoile à l’officier allemand en lui disant « judische [inaudible] ». Aussitôt, l’Allemand pivote sur les talons, et naturellement part tout péteux en la saluant tout de même, mais je n’ai pas besoin de vous dire, évidemment, la duperie dont l’Allemand a été coupable.
David Boder: [In German] Eine Frage, denkt er, dass der Antisemitismus, den die Nazis hier entwickelt haben, dass viel davon noch ist, dass viel noch nach dem Krieg?
Bertha Goldwasser: [In French] Pensez-vous que les allemands vont s’aimer ici en France ? Est-ce qu’il restera encore de...est-ce qu’il restera encore l’antisémitisme...est-ce que les Français, ils vont vraiment se laisser bourrer le crâne, comme on dit, par les Allemands qui, rien que les juifs sont fautifs dans la guerre et c’est les juifs qui l’ont pris quoi, et ça c’est leur mot d’ordre, n’est-ce pas, pour gagner le monde. Que pensez-vous de cela ?
André Richard: Et bien, à mon avis, malheureusement oui. Malheureusement oui, il y a des germes qui restent en France. Et...vous savez, je crois qu’il faut tout faire pour effacer ces germes, car tout de même, n’est-ce pas ces germes arriveront dans la clandestinité à grandir et...à causer beaucoup de mal. Alors à mon avis, il faut arriver à montrer à ces gens-là qu’ils ont eu tort. Et qu’un homme, qu’il soit juif, qu’il soit catholique, qu’il soit protestant, qu’il soit orthodoxe, tout ce qu’on voudra, et bien tous les hommes ont droit à leur part de soleil et à leur part de vie. Et les hommes doivent tous se donner la main et s’entraider...et s’entraimer les uns, les autres. Et faire abstraction de toute religion, qui à mon avis, les divise. Si vous supprimez les religions, vous aurez...fait un grand pas pour la défense de la liberté.
David Boder: [In German] Monsieur Richard, ich danke Ihnen sehr, es war ein...
David Boder: [In English]...I think that the Frenchmen in Chicago and the
David Boder: [In German]...unsere Studenten werden mit großer Interesse diesen Werk anhören.
Bertha Goldwasser: [In French] Monsieur le professeur vous remercie beaucoup. Il espère que les étudiants et aussi les Français qui se trouvent à Chicago vont écouter les tables avec un très grand plaisir.
David Boder: [In German] Danke sehr.
David Boder: [In English] This concludes spool 28 taken from André [inaudible]
André Richard: [In French] Et bien, à l’Opéra, je chante Rigoletto, je chante Faust, je chante Roméo et Juliette.
David Boder: Quel rôle dans Faust ?
André Richard: Euh, Méphisto.
David Boder: Oh, Méphisto ! Vous ne chantez pas Boris Godounov ?
André Richard: Et bien plus tard, j’espère le chanter, je l’ai à l’étude.